you can see
ladies and gentlemen honorable
colleagues
today we are
united here to convey the sakura prize
for the freedom of thought to alexei
navalny the empty chair
in this hemicycle
is here to symbolize once again
unfortunately
that
the laureate of our prize has no freedom
and
with our great
bitterness alexey navalny cannot be with
us today because he's unjustly
being held in a present in a prison of
the russian federation
but dania navalda navalny who is the
daughter of alexey navalny is here with
us today she is here to represent him
together with the head of cabinet leonid
volkov
and kira yarnish is also here
she
is
the press attache of alexei navalny on
behalf of all of you we would like to
express
our
welcome to you
and to thank you for being here with us
today but i would like to ask you to
take a look at a video dedicated to the
florida of this year
[Applause]
[Music]
russia is being run as a kleptocracy as
a regime which
primary purpose is corruption is to
squeeze funds from wherever possible
[Music]
and when someone like navalny tries to
prevent it
that's when human rights violations
start
and then thousands of people are
arrested at protests
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
what alexi navalny has done recently
goes far beyond the particular issue of
fighting corruption
it's no longer just a fight against
corruption
but a fight for basic human values
a fight for life
[Applause]
senor signori
ladies and gentlemen
honorable colleagues 2021
is the year
in which we celebrate the centenary of
andrei sakharov in his peaceful struggle
to promote human rights his
courageous
fight against the russian and soviet
regime
is the prize that we developed and which
we are going to be handing over today
andrei zakharov would probably be sad
but maybe also proud
to know that for 30 years since
the fall of communism the prize of which
carries his name is being given to
alexei navalny his compatute
but if this bitterness and sadness can
be motivated because the political
regime in russia today
is to be blamed for the prevention of
organization of civil society to limit
freedom of the press to put
political opponents in prison without
any doubt without any doubt
zakarov would be proud proud of the
determination with which alexey novalti
is fighting for human rights and for
fundamental freedoms
the courage that alexei has shown
is
something that causes admiration and
surprise he's been threatened he's been
tortured he's been poisoned
he's been arrested
he's been incarcerated
but they have not been able to actually
make him uh stop speaking he has been
fighting
tirelessly for the russian people he's
an activist fighting corruption he was a
candidate political candidate
and he's a blogger
and he's a lawyer
in other words
his
his action for the freedom of thought
freedom of expression
is here today
and clearly recognized by us
as an absolute value
as he himself said once
corruption prospers if there is no
respect for human rights
and i believe he's right
i think
that the fight against corruption
is a fight
for the respect of human rights of
universal human rights
and it is surely a fight for human
dignity
for good government
and for the rule of law
and in order to defend these principles
which alex say
has been put in prison and has almost
lost his life
he's a political prisoner
and on behalf of the european parliament
i
call upon his immediate release and
unconditional release
for me
as every year i also urgently uh call
upon
all those that need to be released those
laureates who received the sacrifice who
are still in jail
padaway
sergey sicarnowski
mikalai stopkievic
two
laureates of the 2020
zakarov prize and they have been
unfairly
condemned yesterday by the illegitimate
government of belarus
to 18 and 15 years imprisonment
this isn't a shame
because amongst the hundreds of
political prisoners in belarus
there are four
sacral of prize laureates
maria koleskinovia
and alex bialitzy
and other laureates of the cross soccer
surprise are suffering vexation dr
mcguive who has to face up to an
alarming increase in of intimate
intimidations and death threats
this is also
uh true for memoriam the 2009 uh zachary
of laureate one of the
uh
most
ancient voices of protect for human
rights in russia this is also subject to
a process of liquidation
in a world where authoritarian regimes
and populist forces are
attacking human rights and are calling
into question fundamental rights all
these
sacrifices and amongst them of course
alexei navalny all of them are showing
all of us
that with their example through their
example
what
it really means to fight for freedom
they are a source of inspiration
for all of us who dream for a better
society a fairer society in russia but
not only in russia
the european parliament will make all
the efforts necessary to support their
battles and to protect them
the
i myself in the european parliament are
hoping impatiently for the day when
alexei navalny can come to the european
parliament can't come back to actually
personally receive the zakar of prize
and now i shall be giving the floor to
miss nevada
the
members of the european parliament
all the member states of the european
union some of them may be remotely
linked are very
impatient to listen to your words
thank you
[Applause]
hi um thank you thank you so much this
is
truly incredible before i start my
speech i
wanted to tell everyone how incredibly
grateful i am to be here accepting this
award for my father and at the same time
absolutely terrified
this is a big honor for me to be able to
stand here in front of all of you
and as a 20 year old college student who
doesn't know much about politics i'm
very much afraid and anxious to mess
this up
thank you
thank you
when i first heard that my dad alexey
navalny was giving the sacrifice i was
extremely happy for two reasons
the first one this is a tremendous honor
recognition of his merits and a high
praise of the work that has been done
and is continuing to be done by him and
his co-workers
and most importantly it's a single it's
a signal to those tens of millions of
citizens in my country who are
continuing to fight
uh for the better fate of russia
i will also name the second reason
although it's a little frank and awkward
my father is receiving this award from
the european parliament and when you
receive such an award you get to come
and speak in front of the european
parliament
unfortunately for obvious reasons he
wasn't able to be here today and i
thought to myself well
i guess someone better run and get that
ticket to strasbourg and seize the
opportunity to come and
well
um
see this wonderful thing for myself
and over some time i realized that
this might actually be
what the nightmare of myself and my
family looks like
me traveling from different to different
conferences
and summits giving speeches in my dad's
name
sometimes he's even awarded something
but i'm the one traveling i'm the one
writing the speech and starting it with
a joke
while he's
in jail and i will continue traveling
meanwhile reading articles about the
horrible conditions my dad is being held
in
it's not like there's much to do about
it so i travel and speak and he
continues to be held in confinement
and this doesn't only concern alexi
navalny were the last years laureates
the belarus opposition now mostly in
prison
where's the 2010 nobel peace prize
laureate lucia
he died in prison
and here i asked myself today
why is it so hard to free from captivity
those who are fighting for human rights
why
are they still thrown in jail not only
all over the world but in european
geographically european countries in the
21st century
europe
is grey and almighty
the will of the european citizens is
expressed by the resolutions of the
members of the european parliament
and those are precise
correct and fair resolutions
they're supported by the united kingdom
united states australia new zealand and
the whole free world
but those who are like my father
continue sitting in prison watching more
and more of their allies being thrown
behind bars
you know i've heard this many times and
sure i will again maybe even in the
quarters after this ceremony you know
dasha they'll say to me
i understand why are you feeling this
way because it concerns your family
and close ones but in the real world
however we have to be more pragmatic
and in those hallways i'll nod my head
and say
yes of course what else i can say
i'm a 20 year old college student and i
don't feel very comfortable arguing with
ex with experienced and responsible
pragmatics
however here today taking advantage of
the fact that i have the microphone
um no one will take it away from me and
i have i don't have to argue with anyone
personally feeling impolite i would like
to oppose that pragmatism
this is the sucker of christ
[Applause]
this is the sakura of christ and andrei
sahirov was probably one of the most
non-pragmatic people on the planet
i don't understand why those who
advocate for pragmatic relations with
the
dictators
can't simply open the history books
it would be a very pragmatic act
and having it done
it's very easy to understand the
inescapable political law
the pacification of dictators and
tyrants never works
no matter how many people try to deceive
themselves hoping that
another madman who clings to power will
behave decently in response to
concessions and flirtations it will
never happen
the very essence of authoritarian power
involves a constant increase in bets an
increase in aggression and the search
for new enemies
and those who once said let's not push
lokochenko and continue the dialogue
when he was beating people up and
throwing them behind bars achieve only
that now in order to sentence someone
lokochenko has to stop a whole passenger
plane
another thing that pragmatists
don't want to do for some reason
which urges them to remember about the
expenses and academic economic losses is
simply to pick up a calculator and see
how much their pragmatism costs in
particular to the european taxpayers
years of flirting with putin made it
clear to him
that to increase his ratings
he can't start a war how much word will
the world with ukraine cost to europe
even now
with so many news on russian troops
coming to the ukraine border no one's
really talking about it
no pragmatic trade corporation will
recoup the share of the direct laws that
will have to be incurred
not to mention the cost of the time of
the western politicians like yourselves
have already spent on solving the
problem instead of dealing with their
own affairs in their own countries
one of the opposition leaders parisian
top
is killed with shots in the back right
by the kremlin
and then comes the pragmatist and says
well we can't do much about it
let's limit ourselves to a tough
statement and then continue the
conversation
and then
they'll kill the second and the third
and the fourth will be killed in the
center of berlin and the fifth in the uk
and then they also blow up some
warehouses in europe
and then they start killing with
chemical weapons
and now
we know it's just
and what we know is just unsuccessful
assassination attempts
how many were successful
we already know
that a real terrorist group has been
created inside putin's special services
killing citizens of my country without a
hearing or trial
without justice
they were close to killing my mother
they nearly killed killed my father
and no one will guarantee that tomorrow
european politicians won't start falling
dead by simply touching a north doorknob
and now
you're already increasing the police
budget you give a lot of money to
special services
spend billions on new ways to detect
those toxic substances
and these are the consequences of
pragmatism
don't push it we need to act carefully
and not anger them says the pragmatists
and tomorrow dictators inspired by half
measure measures
of the western of the west will
transport thousands of people to the
border of the european union forcing
women and children to storm the fences
and secretly dreaming of someone being
shot or trampled in the crowd
let pragmatists answer how much will
cause will it cost poland or lithuania
or the entire european union
they will answer to me
what do you want these are sovereign
states
they have their own governments our
capabilities are very limited
are you proposing a nuclear war
to free the political prisoners of
course i don't propose starting a war
however
i will not
i will note that although it's not
successful it has started
and there are real victims and they're
both and they're using both cyber and
chemical weapons
the fact that european banks
freely launder corrupted billions of
putin and his friends
the yaas the yachts of putin's oligarchs
continue being sensations on european
mediterranean
that 99
of top officials of russia and belarus
directly involved in crimes
are all still freely
uh allowed to travel in europe just like
their families are all sure signs
that many of those who make decisions
don't even try to win at least the small
wars in this battle
they talk too much
and think about the realm of politics
considering actions based on ideas and
principles which frankly are naive and
stupid and you know what it seems to me
that the problem is that the desire to
appeal to the dictators again and again
not to anger him to ignore his crimes as
long as it's possible is not a pragmatic
approach at all
it's time to say it straight
under the sign of pragmatism there is
cynicism hypocrisy and corruption
there is a constant war between idealism
and pragmatism
there are fierce battles
in the european politics but even
choosing the side of pragmatism
shouldn't mean betraying your ideas
when i wrote to my dad and asked what
exactly do you want me to say in the
speech from your
point
he answered
say that there
that no one can dare to equate russia to
putin's regime
russia is a part of europe and we strive
to become a part of it
but we also
but we also want europe to strive for
itself
to those amazing principles
which are at its core
we strive for europe of ideas the
celebration of human rights democracy
and integrity
and we don't want europe of chancellors
and ministers who dream of getting a job
on the board of putin's state-owned
companies or sailing on oligarch's
yachts
today
on the stage receiving this
high amazing award for my father alexei
navalny i thank you
and through all of you i welcome the
europe of ideas and principles european
union is an incredible miracle created
by nations
whose whole history is an endless war
with each other despite all the
difficulties and problems however the eu
has and will encounter i believe that in
its future
that one day my country will become a
part of it
to finish the speech i want to quote a
great company a compatriot of mine and
whose honor this award was named
my destiny was in some sense exceptional
not because of false modesty but because
of a wish to be accurate and i know that
my destiny has turned out to be larger
than my personality
i simply tried to live up to my own
destiny i hope we all have the strength
to live up to our destinies freedom told
lexi nevalni thank you
so
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
so
so
you